hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast circuits reward
motivation and decisions linking
connectivity to function and disease
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this presentation has
been approved for category 1 continuing
medical education credits by Loma Linda
University if you are interested in
obtaining CMI's after attending this
presentation please click on the get
your free CME C e credits button in the
bottom left corner of the event screen
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of a presentation window we'll try
to answer as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the green screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the Green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Suzanne Haven dr.
Havers research focuses on the neural
network underline learning and
decision-making that leads to action
plan development pathology of this
network is implicated in several mental
health disorders including drug
addiction obsessive-compulsive disorder
and schizophrenia the lab is in
addressing the hypothesis that cortical
basal ganglia connections are critical
for integrating information across
functional domains dr. Hebert
received her PhD and neuro and bio
behavioral sciences from Stanford
University they will now turn it over to
dr. Hebert for presentation good morning
and thank you for joining me today I'm
going to be talking about circuits of
reward and motivation in decision
and linking this complex network and
circuitry to function and disease and as
you can see from this beginning slide
this circuitry and network is really
quite complex we won't cover all of
these connections but just a few key
ones and I'm going to emphasize
particularly those that are associated
with a number of mental health disorders
on this side of the slide you can see a
human brain which is very complex cortex
and some of the dysfunctions within the
circuitry that you can see in some of
the mental health diseases and we'll
talk about this as we go through the
presentation today but before we start
that up just a little bit of history the
idea that the reward circuit were
motivation lies embedded within in the
cortex in the in the brain and is not
really sensory driven but internally
driven was first described by a very
classic study by oles Miller in which
they injected or passed electrodes into
various regions of the brain and asked
the animal to work for particular
stimulation in those areas and as you
can see number of internal structures
were highly activated during these
stimulation experiments support for this
internal circuit then came from
pharmacological manipulations in which
intracranial injections of drugs abuse
demonstrated those same structures in
particular highlighted here are the
dopamine neurons in the ventral
tegmental area and the ventral striatum
as well as other structures in which the
animals work very hard to get little
bits of drugs and abuse injected into
those areas as I mentioned though the
reward activity related is is found
throughout the brain but particularly in
these two brain regions
the brunette brain dopamine cells and
the nucleus accumbens ventral striatum
but also prefrontal cortex and I'm
focusing a little bit more on prefrontal
cortex because of course that's the area
of the brain that makes us very human
and where most of our mental health
problems arise from so if you just look
at these two charts you can see about
the publication's and the imaging
studies that are related to these three
brain regions have really skyrocketed in
the last few years and in particular
dopamine the prefrontal cortex and the
ventral striatum and all of the other
areas combined are either less focused
on so I'm going to briefly talk about
the but dopamine neurons it's difficult
to have a talk about reward without
including these important cells so this
is a classic set of experiments from a
number of different laboratories well
from Schultz's classic studies on the
ability to demonstrate how the dopamine
neurons detect war a reward our reward
detection error ourselves in which one a
surprising reward occurs these cells
fire in response to that surprise and
this has been now very well demonstrated
through a number of futures of recent
studies to demonstrate how well the
dopamine neurons are associated with
reward but even before that of course
there are a number of pharmacological
studies demonstrating blocking the
dopamine in blocking Liebherr pressing
foreign frienemy just to give you a
little orientation this is of course the
dopamine activation in a human imaging
studies and down here in the right part
of this slide demonstrates the actual
distribution of dopamine cells the
classic VTA ventral tegmental area
dopamine that's been associated with
reward but as well from Schultz's
studies so clearly show
many of the cells in the substantia
[ __ ] pars compacta also demonstrate
response to reward and in this section
we see a human coronal section staying
four th which is one of the enzymes
associated with dopamine and you can see
the distribution of the dopamine cells
in this slide the nucleus accumbens
again is way of orientation this is in
the ventral striatum and many studies
have demonstrated also the activation of
these cells during a reward paradigm to
human studies again demonstrating the
activation in the ventral striatum
during tasks that are associated with
reward prediction error and with various
kinds of reward in terms of receiving
particular monetary rewards for tasks in
this lower panel we have little
orientation of the human brain a coronal
section with the caudate nucleus the
internal capsule the putamen and the
ventral striatum also referred to as the
nucleus accumbens and I'm going to be
using those two terms fairly
interchangeably and finally the last
area we'll be talking about is
prefrontal cortex and specifically we're
going to be talking about three
different areas the orbital and anterior
cingulate cortex which can be divided
into what I'm referring to here is the
ventral medial prefrontal cortex and
that includes areas thirty-two and
twenty-five this region and parts of ten
and this area right you can't see it
very well because it's embedded here in
the midline the orbital cortex which is
in the orbital surface of the brain and
adore some anterior cingulate cortex
which is in this more dorsal region
around the corpus callosum and these
three areas have been associated with
different
diseases the ventral medial prefrontal
cortex is associated among other things
with chronic depression and fear and
PTSD the orbital cortex is associated
with obsessive-compulsive disorder and
addiction and the dorsal anterior
cingulate cortex is led to many many
different psychiatric diseases including
OCD addictions schizophrenia and a host
of others and again just to give you
some background and the activation of
these areas during reward and motivation
and this was one of many many different
studies demonstrating activation during
a reward probabilistic task in the
ventral medial prefrontal cortex and up
into the dorsal anterior cingulate
cortex and over into the orbital
prefrontal cortex now these three areas
although they're very clearly linked to
each other as well as in general
decision-making they seem to have
somewhat different functional correct
domains the ventral medial prefrontal
cortex is important in computing a
chosen value do I like raisins better
than apples for example the OFC is
important for linking a stimulus to
their values in other words very
critical in learning and pairing
different actions with with a value and
the dorsal anterior cingulate is
important in monitoring errors and
conflict to switch behaviors have I had
enough apples and do I now need some
raisins or do I want to make this choice
versus that choice and so these areas
have been shown with the number of
studies they have slightly different
functional attributes what I want to
talk about in this take
their address then is how these three
areas interact with the basal ganglia
and in particular focus on this basal
ganglia cortical reward Network but
importantly how those connections
interface with both cognitive and motor
circuits that help us develop action
plans and habits that is as we move
through life we make decisions and those
decisions are based on motivation and
reward but ultimately result in a
particular motor action the second part
of the talk which is you'll see will be
somewhat related to the first is how the
pathways or the white matter or the
connections of these areas get to their
targets and this is very important in
this connectivity profiles for
understanding neural imaging studies and
abnormalities in the diseases and I'm
going to use deep brain stimulation
which is a targeted approach therapeutic
approach for psychiatric and
neurological disorders as an example for
how one can think about specific
pathways and connections being
associated with disabilities so to start
with I'm going to start with how the
reward circuit as part of the basal
ganglia is that's actually put together
and many of you may already know that
the basal ganglia has been classically
part of the motor system but in the late
70s Leonard Homer demonstrated that a
part of the limbic cortex actually
projected to a region that we refer to
as the striatum and so he demonstrated
that not only the motor system projected
to the striatum but the limbic system
did as well and that projected as the
motor system gives the output nuclei of
the substantial [ __ ] and the pallidum
those projected them to the a part of
the thalamus and back to the cortex
which is the classic direct cortical
basal ganglia camp
in addition there's the classic indirect
pathway through the subthalamic nucleus
again um part of the limbic pathway as
well as the motor pathway and then
finally there's a hyper direct pathway
from the cortex to the STM is that your
basic circuitry in addition the ventral
striatum has a unique projection which
gets information both by hippocampus and
the amygdala after this circuit had been
demonstrated Alexander and DeLong at all
that showed that the basal ganglia
really was comprised of several
different circuits including this limbic
circuit that I just described but a
motor circuit in their cognitive circuit
etc and they discussed the idea that
this Catanese pathways were segregated
and and parallel in their processing but
about the same time that the ventral
system was discovered those working in
psychiatry and in the ventral system
realized that there had to be ways in
which the limbic or the reward system
the cognitive system and the motor
system were integrated and didn't just
simply operate in a parallel pathway
because through an integration we begin
to understand how motivation can impact
on cognition and our motor plans and I'm
going to talk now about three places in
which this integration can occur through
the basal ganglia there are other areas
but these are the key ones that I want
to focus on today first of all I'm going
to talk about the cortical the striatal
dopamine striatal connection I'm going
to
about the cortical striatal connection
and finally I'm going to talk about the
hyper direct pathway to the STM so the
idea about integration across the the
dopamine neurons also has a history and
we know that the striatum projects to
the pars reticulata of the substantia
[ __ ] but they also project densely to
the dopamine neurons and now in the late
70s showed that in the rodent the
striatum projected to thee dopamine
neurons in a larger area and therefore
had the opportunity to impact on motor
regions of the striatum and this was
then demonstrated using e/m as well we
then showed that the reciprocal
connections between these two was very
complicated here's the limbic area of
the striatum the cognitive area of the
striatum and in blue the motor areas of
the striatum now what we showed was that
there were three components of this
reciprocal connection within the
substantia [ __ ] first and most commonly
thought of it was the reciprocal
component what that means was that
projections from the ventral striatum to
the [ __ ] and the [ __ ] dopamine neurons
back to the striatum were from the same
regions of each area that was true for
the limbic the cognitive and motor
moreover however you can see these
little dots these dots represent the
cells that are projecting back to these
functionally identified regions of the
striatum here the blue dots would are
projecting to the motor region yellow
dots to the cognitive region and red
dots to the limbic region what that
demonstrates is that these projections
to those areas are not embedded within
the
within the terminal fields of that
functional region and likewise what you
have here are terminals with no dots
that means this region is getting input
from cognitive rate areas but not
projecting to it when we put these
together what you find is that not only
does the limbic region project back to
the limbic region it also projects to
cells that terminate in the more dorsal
areas or the cognitive areas and these
then project also to a region of the
[ __ ] that in turn projects to the motor
so we have a kind of a spiral movement
from limbic to cognitive to motor parts
of the striatum and this is actually
demonstrated also in across different
species of animals as indicated here in
a rodent study and using that kind of
design what we very ever in his
colleagues demonstrated that this spiral
between the limbic cognitive and motor
aspects of the stride Elmyra striatal
connection was very important to that
and underlies the shift from an action
outcome to stimulus response mechanisms
in the control over drug seeking and in
this study by Linda Perino at all shows
how after chronic cocaine use the
movement of glucose utilization moves
from the ventral to dorsal striatum
presumably through this mechanism so
what that said was as the cortex is
projecting to these various different
parts of the striatum the striatum and
the [ __ ] itself are interacting in a
way in which the ventral parts of the
striatum influence over time the more
dorsal parts or the motor output parts
of the striatum
what about this cortical input we now
turn to our our interest into how these
projections from the regions I was
referring to impact on the striatum
itself according to the parallel
pathways connectivity profile that was
demonstrated by Alexander DeLong etc if
this parallel processing occurred then
all of these areas should be projecting
to the striatum in a point-to-point
manner but what we found was in fact
that isn't entirely the case again
there's history behind this we find that
there's many different studies that
shows for example no part of the caudate
putamen is under the sole influence of
one functional region of cortex and
here's if just a few of the quotes that
have demonstrated the history of knowing
that or understanding about these
projection systems are much more complex
and here's a study in the rat which was
very beautifully demonstrated that one
axon cortical axon in Australia really
occupies a large part of the striatum so
in looking at the striatum we also know
that there are many parts of the
striatum that contain real org activity
related activity that are found in the
dorsal parts of the stratum in here
three studies that demonstrate that thus
reward is not just limited to the
ventral striatum we looked at this more
closely and what you can see in this
figure is the inputs first of all from
the three cortical regions that I was
referring to in the vmPFC the OFC and
the dorsal anterior cingulate and what
you can see in this coronal section this
is a frontal view a me
you in a lateral view and here's just a
coronal section through those each of
these squiggly lines are is a projection
system from slightly different parts of
these regions they're color-coded so
that red is from the ventral medial
prefrontal cortex fuchsia from orbital
and yellow or orange sorry from the
dorsal anterior cingulate and you can
see that there's a general topography
that you would expect but look beyond
topography to note all of the
interactions that are potentially taking
place on the medial wall you pretty much
have the ventral medial prefrontal and
orbital but as you move a little bit
more laterally you get quite a bit of
mixture from all of these areas and
interestingly collectively these studies
show that these three areas associated
with motivation in the war occupy a
large part of the striatum moreover this
would be our classic ventral striatum
but you can see that this actually
occupies quite a bit of the caudate the
ventral part of the caudate and the
ventral part of the putamen if we and we
super impose additional inputs from
cognitive regions and this is the dorsal
and lateral prefrontal cortex areas that
are known noted for cognition and
executive function what you see again is
the topography as one expects but then
again look through this complexity and
you begin to see how these nodes in
between these are areas in which
convergence between these projections
occur and this occurs mainly in the
rostral part of the striatum if we
look at this in human brain using
probabilistic tractography two different
studies demonstrate a very similar
organization first of all there's the
topography that you expect but again
looking at the orange regions and the
light green regions you begin to see
that there's quite a lot of convergence
between limbic areas and cognitive areas
cognitive areas and premotor areas and
premotor areas and motor areas moreover
interestingly you can it also
demonstrates the large area almost 25%
of the striatum again mostly in the
rostral part of the stratum that is
associated with these reward motivation
functions executive function in this
study shows almost 50 percent or a
little more than 50 percent and despite
the fact that the basal ganglia thought
of the motor structure as you can see
them in fact now that we look at it more
in detail we can see that the motor
aspect or let's say the purely motor
parts of the basal ganglia are
relatively small if we look at these
probabilistic maps in the striatum and
this is an area this is sort of a map
showing where more than one projection
system terminates and this one that I've
outlined here has four different areas
dorsal anterior synced orbital ventral
lateral and dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex due to cognitive and two limbic
areas and also caudal cingulate cortex
and parietal cortex and you can see that
these areas form then potentially a
potential note here within the striatum
it's important for integrating across
different functions we wanted to know
whether or not the there's the
possibility that these are functional no
and this is some preliminary data using
resting-state data and using a seed
placed in the region of the striatum
that we feel should has these convergent
inputs and what you can see from the
resting state data is as we would
predict areas in the anterior cingulate
in the dorsal prefrontal cortex the
ventral lateral prefrontal cortex
ventral medial dorsal medial prefrontal
cortex and parietal cortex suggesting
that these nodes that we see using
probabilistic methods also have a
functional underpinning so I should say
that the reverse that within the
functional data we can see that these
structural underpinnings are consistent
with that we'll return to the idea of
different parts of the striatum having
these convergent inputs later in the
talk so in conclusion to this part we
should see that there's a convergence
between different reward processing
regions and the dorsal anterior and
orbital cortex also converge especially
in the rostral part of the striatum
which creates certain sites that may be
particularly important in incentive
based learning it also may be
particularly important switch points
that may be effective in disease the
last slide I'm going to talk about in
terms of the integration across is the
hyper direct pathway again the cortical
inputs to the basal ganglia system are
particularly important in understanding
how the system is integrated and so we
ask the question whether the hyper
direct pathway to the STM this is again
a review of the of the STM's place in
the
in the cortical basal ganglia system
this is the indirect pathway embedded
here but the hyper direct pathway is a
way in which cortex impacts directly on
the SDN and here we can see a charting
of the pathways from different parts of
cortex again the details are not
important the main point is if you look
at the color coding similar to what I
showed before you see that here's a
coronal section of the STM the limbic
part in this medial region the motor
part in the dorsal and lateral area the
cognitive part embedded in the middle in
the premotor areas somewhere in between
what you can see is there's a topography
as we saw in the cortical striatal
connections but a lot of overlap again
the reason I'm bringing this up is that
we will look at this in more detail when
we get to the deep brain stimulation as
we pass electrodes through various
therapies through these regions we want
to be clear about what areas we really
want to stimulate so we'll be coming
back to this as well so what I'd like to
do now is switch to the pathways that
connect these areas and as I mentioned
it's critical to know how they get to
those targets and here we'll be talking
mainly about the cortical targets not
the basal ganglia targets and the
implications of these pathways for
understanding imaging studies and as I
said I will be talking about deep brain
stimulation as an example of how we can
specifically target pathways and
connections so first of all a little bit
of review of the history of the imaging
studies which has really exploded in the
last few years these imaging studies
show abnormalities and connectivity
profiles in many different psychiatric
diseases
this chart just demonstrates the MRI
studies in MRI demonstrating MRI
abnormalities in these five five
diseases if any a depression OCD PTSD in
addiction and in this screen we see the
diffusion imaging of the white matter
tracts that connect these areas that I'm
going to be talking about and that
includes the white matter tracts
particularly the corpus callosum
internal capsule and the cingulum bundle
and you can see how these have exploded
as well and now they are very much
associated with different diseases so
what is diffusion imaging it's it's a
way in which one can look at white
matter integrity in the white matter and
to track particular pathways it's a
sequence that studies XO mo structure
and bundle coherence and it's a
measurement of water diffusion molecules
across white matter and therefore it is
an indirect measure of pathways and as I
mentioned it's used to link connectivity
with abnormalities in particular areas
in here three different studies that
show the red that's I identified you can
see the white matter you know in these
studies and the right and the red
indicates abnormalities in the FA values
and this slide expressed in depressed
versus healthy controls this slide is
demonstrating a study in OCD and and
this is also in depressed individuals
compared to healthy controls and what
you can see is that in these white
matters you don't see the entire white
matter outlined in FA hai FA values but
here for example a specific part of the
internal capsule
and the question is what specific fibers
might be going through those regions so
what I'm going to do first is define the
organization of our fibers through the
white matter and I'm only going to give
you some examples of understanding some
organizational rules in which the fibers
use to get to where they're going we'll
talk a little bit about the ability to
segment these bundles then based on
functional connections the implications
for understanding and interpreting the
imaging studies I just showed you and
then importantly using this data to
understand the abnormalities that we see
in in MRI and how we can think about
what we're targeting in specific kinds
of therapeutic approaches deep brain
stimulation being the example of what
I'm going to show you so the first thing
I'm going to do is tell you a little bit
about one rule and the rule is on the
ventral surface this is a coronal
section of the ventral surfaces of the
ventral medial prefrontal cortex and the
orbital and I'm going to tell you about
one rule which is the medial lateral
portal cortical position dictates where
the fibers will travel in the internal
capsule and in the corpus callosum so
let's
talk about the internal capsule as
fibers from the ventral medial
prefrontal cortex enter the internal
capsule they come up through the ventral
surface they pass through and they move
more dorsally in contrast those from the
lateral surface arc around and come into
the internal capsule from the dorsal
surface and move ventrally the result is
those that are in the medial region
occupied the ventral part of the
internal capsule and those are in the
lateral B region occupy a more dorsal
perspective the other thing that's
important to point out as you can see
that the internal capsule doesn't end at
the anterior commissure but actually
goes through the anterior commissure and
and include some fascicles that are
underneath the anterior commissure the
same is true with the corpus callosum
the medial fibers from the medial region
cross the corpus callosum ventral to
those from the lateral parts of the
orbital circus circuit which cross or
dorsally so what that means then and if
I can go back on slide what mean that
means is I want you to think about the
internal capsule then is starting to be
segmented according to what passes
through each of these places this is no
longer just a combination of random
fibers but actually has a clear
organization as does the corpus callosum
I'm going to be showing you a film right
now
chose the and I since I can't speak
during the film I want to describe what
you're going to see you're going to see
the injection site an injection site
here in the ventral medial prefrontal
cortex and the flow of the fibers as
they pass through different areas what
you will first see is a little bit of an
orientation of the brain the injection
site will come on or the seed that we
place will come on you will see the
fibers growing they don't actually grow
of course but they go through the
uncinate fasciculus they'll go through
the cingulum bundle they will then pass
through the internal capsule they will
divide into the thalamus and brainstem
and the amygdala fugle pathway will come
out and then you will also see a fiber
pathways - to be another fiber pathway
to the amygdala so if we could show the
film
you
okay the next film you're gonna see is
going to be that same see the next film
you'll see is a film of all three areas
all these three areas together to give
you the understanding of how these
different fibers relate to each other I
want you to particularly identify the
internal capsule and the corpus callosum
and their organization in in those
bundles could be at the next film please
you
okay so in the last film you saw in a
deep brain stimulation electrode
entering into the internal capsule which
is one of the sites and so now we're
going to switch to deep brain
stimulation and I'd like the next film
please the brain is made up of millions
of connections between neurons that
control movement and behavior different
areas of the brain have different
regulatory effects on these neural
networks disruption of the regulatory
portions of these networks leads to
various neurologic and psychological
diseases such as Parkinson's disease and
essential tremor deep brain stimulation
has been found to relieve the symptoms
of certain of these diseases that are
resistant to medications deep brain
stimulation involves surgically
inserting an electrode into the central
portion of the brain in the part called
the basal ganglia the electrode is then
connected to a generator similar to a
cardiac pacemaker the rapid firing of
electrode interrupts the abnormal
networks relieving symptoms such as
tremor and muscle rigidity in
Parkinson's disease before current
medical therapy was available
Parkinson's disease was treated with the
blade of surgery which involved the non
reversible destruction of brain tissue
with deep brain stimulation the firing
of the electrode can be adjusted in an
outpatient setting in order to control
the symptoms but to minimize unwanted
side-effects
currently deep brain stimulation is
approved by the FDA for the treatment of
Parkinson's disease
essential tremor and dystonia resistant
to medical care
ongoing research is studying the
treatment of severe depression and
obsessive-compulsive disorder by
stimulating alternative areas of the
brain
okay so now I'm going to switch to deep
brain stimulation and again as I
mentioned this is not only an
interesting therapeutic approach but
also want to use this as a way of
emphasizing the importance of
understanding the connectivity that
we've been talking about so far in this
lecture so there are a couple of
different targets that are have been
used now worldwide in various groups
probably the most prominent one which is
why I talk a little bit about the stn is
the subthalamic nucleus for Parkinson's
disease this target is also now being
explored for obsessive-compulsive
disorder in the more medial parts of the
target mostly in the in some of the
European experimental mental health
disorders have been focused mainly on
OCD and depression but also on addiction
and the targets here in the US are
mainly the internal capsule in the
ventral striatum and the sub genuine
cingulate white matter these are the
ones I'm gonna focus on but I'm aware
that and you all are aware I think that
there are a number of other targets that
people are experimenting with throughout
the brain but these are the ones that
are probably been investigated the most
the most so far there's the internal
capsule target we'll talk a little bit
about that one of the intro that stn
will start actually with the STM target
the ventral striatum target the internal
capsule and the sub general white matter
target so as I showed you before the
pathways that are connecting the
cortical pathways in the hyper direct
pathway that connects the STM and of
course we didn't go over the palo how
no indirect connections but let's focus
on the electrode in the hyper direct
pathway here's the a model of the
electrode you can see the four contacts
you can stimulate each of these
separately or in combination and what
you can see is that if you are aiming
for the motor areas which are the blue
regions you probably want to activate
your more dorsal and lateral contact and
if you are interested in affecting more
the mental health areas in particular
OCD you're going to aim more closely to
the more medial and ventral areas let me
give you I have one small film on the
internal capsule if we could show that
or now that would be great
you
so what you saw there were the cortical
fibers that are going through the
internal capsule and not limited to the
areas that I have focused on before but
also including the medial prefrontal
cortex the anterior cingulate etc and
now you can see again in the different
four contents that we have depending on
the contact that is activated will
depend on which fiber pathways or which
combination of fiber pathways you're
going to likely be activating the
advantage of these methods is that as
the patient's outcomes are evaluated one
can change which particular contact is
being activated in the parameters and
therefore to effect the most the best
outcome possible and of course this is
in contrast to lesion where of course
the it's irreversible so this is a big
advantage and you can see how many
options you might have in this using
this technique we talked about the
connections in cortical striatal
connections and I just wanted to again
think about if you were doing DBS or OCD
in the ventral striatum or for addiction
again placing your electrode in the
ventral striatum this whole region these
little stars because it's difficult to
see the contacts indicate the contact
points within the striatum and again you
can see that if you in general when we
stimulate very very ventrally it's not
as an effective site because you might
have quite a bit of anxiety there as you
can imagine you have a lot of the very
basic limbic structures passing through
here and as you move up you begin to
activate or capture fibers not only from
limbic regions but for more some of them
were caught
of regions the dorsal anterior cingulate
et cetera once again like the DBS for
the internal capsule you can see it's a
very similar trajectory you have lots of
different options and potential choices
on PBS and the sub general cingulum
which has been a target for depression
you can see the white matter here really
is activates or involves I'm sorry the
white matter here lots of different
potential pathways and here I have a
schematic below of those pathways that
are likely to be involved in again each
of these contents in the most medial and
ventral position of course you will
activate all of the areas or capture
fibers from the ventral medial
prefrontal cortex and in this entire
region you also will be capturing many
fibers for more lateral areas that are
passing through the electrode to go to
other parts of cortex the the more
dorsal contents will be capturing part
of the ventral aspects of the corpus
callosum and if you recall the int
ventral aspects of the corpus callosum
again carry a lot of the medial fibers
from this region so what gets stimulated
at the different targets are somewhat
different
each target and each contact will have a
different combination of fibers that
could contribute to the therapeutic
effect just comparing here the so
genuine and the the internal capsule and
ventral striatum you will in both of
those you'll be getting the a sending
and descending thalamic and brainstem
fibers in the sub genuine you will also
be capturing many of the cortical and
subcortical projections that are coming
from areas near the electrode this will
be capturing cortical quarter
direct cortical cortical connections
while the internal capsule won't the
main point then is that we can segment
white matter bundles much as we do the
gray matter with specific areas with
each bundle that's associated with
reward and cognitive control
connectivity and allowing us then to
think about imaging studies and this is
one of many inspire me to Goldstein and
looking at drug addicted versus control
subjects and you can see that the FA
values change and as I mentioned before
in specific parts of the internal
capsule and in the cingulum bundle in
the corpus callosum and by understanding
and here we have the other studies that
I showed you before by understanding how
these different pathways are passed
through these different systems we begin
to have a better idea about what
connectivity is actually interrupted
during these diseases so in conclusion
then to the whole talk I'd like to
mention again that we talked about
crosstalk between basal ganglia circuits
through several levels in the network
and I only highlighted three of those
the cortical striatal the cortical [ __ ]
striatal and the cortical stn but it
provides a anatomical mechanism for
integrating across reward and value into
decision-making and I also showed you
evidence that this structural
connectivity is then played out also in
functional connectivity in terms of some
of the functional resting state
distributed networks that we see
moreover this helps us think about
targets
and ways of approaching different parts
of the basal cortical basal ganglia
circuit for therapeutic disease
approaches to disease whatever I also
talked about how pathways between
related cortical areas follow specific
rules to get to their target and this
allows us to segment white matter much
the way we do gray matter in terms of
function and explore in more detail how
abnormality and connections that we see
in diffusion studies can be linked to
specific connections and helping us
understand some of the therapeutic
invasive part targets such as deep brain
stimulation or lesions or even non
invasive ones as we move forward to non
invasive ones such as TMS and that's it
there are many people in the lab that
I'd like to thank and if I if there's
time for questions I'm happy to to take
questions
thank you dr. Hebert for that
interesting presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
period I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as our first
question posed to slide 37 please
explain the yellow dots more is each one
of functioning synapse or a fiber bundle
it's I hope this is the slide you are
referring to slide 37 each of these is
indicating the fibers so this area where
we're tracking the fibers that are
coming from this part of cortex into the
internal capsule so the fibers these are
the exons would leave this region and
move dorsally through the caudate
white-matter into the internal capsule
these are fibers from this region of
cortex the reason they look as if they
are interrupted and it's not one fiber
bundle it's because they are traveling
through these small fascicles these are
these white matter fan suppose you can
see one here budding off so they are
fibers that are going into into the
internal capsule
thank you dr. Hebert unfortunately we
are out of time I want to thank our
audience for their interesting questions
and participation in today's event I'd
like to thank dr. Suzanne Hebert for her
informative presentation today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
for the next few months and you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
new to when this webcast will be
available for replay we encourage you to
share this email with any colleagues who
may have missed today's event thank you
very much very attendance would see you
next time